so how do i work this out um how do i
determine these values
uh c1 and c2 well later on when you get
further into the topic of integration
you'll see
that one of the handy things we can do
is just try some values test out some
values if you if you know anything about
these functions
and see what happens some values are
easier than others
and the value that i'm going to test out
is testing when
x equals 0. what happens when x equals
0.
now you might say test x equals 0 test
it where and the answer
is test it where m and t and
x are all living together where are m t
and x
all living together and interacting and
the answer is on our very first line
here
where we defined uh what m and t were
they were these sort of unknown
functions right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take this line here oops it is i keep
doing that
and then take this here and i'm going to
substitute in x equals 0 and see
what happens so i'm going to paste that
here
so let's see what happens when i put in
uh x equals zero into this and you'll
see why i chose zero
uh there's only one place to substitute
x into it's it's right here so it's
going to be
e to the power of i times zero last time
i checked
i times 0 is 0. so i've got e to the
power of 0 here
and then you've got this nothing has
changed on the right-hand side because
there's no place
for our x to be substituted into
however i can actually gain something
from this right because i know what e to
the 0
is it's it's one right so if
i know this over here is not just any
complex number now it's a specific one
it's the one whose modulus and argument
leads me
to the spot one on the complex number
plane
where is that i haven't drawn a complex
number plane in this entire proof
let's just draw ourselves a complex
plane here so i've got my
real bit here my imaginary bit here
where is
one on the complex plane the answer is
it's right there
there's one okay what's the modulus to
this spot well it's the distance from
the origin so it's going to be
that number there which in this case is
just one unit
and then what's my argument well it's my
angle measured from the positive real
axis
so you start on the positive real axis
and then you measure up to
what angle will face toward your complex
number but the angle facing towards my
complex number
is going to be well on the positive real
axis so there is no angle the angle is
zero so therefore what i can say is i
can rewrite one
in polar form right it's going to be a
modulus of one
multiplied by the argument should be
zero so it'll be cos
of zero plus i sine
of 0 and then everything else is the
same on the
right hand side so what you can see here
is when x equals
0 i should write that down when x equals
0.
what can we say about m and t well
m will equal what did we just say that
modulus will be 1
over there and t that's the argument
will equal
0. so what i can do is i can say oh that
goes into this line here m
is going to be 1 in here so i can
draw a line up to here
and i get m equals 1
and then i can do the same thing over
here with t equals zero
when x equals zero t equals zero so i've
got zero
equals zero plus c two so
this constant here clearly equals zero
so
now i can say since
we'll do it here since c2
equals zero t is just equal to
x plus zero which is just x
so all of that has finally got us to a
conclusion
you can see here i started with this
line
duplicate that this down here and i can
say oh
um m and t are not unknown anymore i've
got a value for m
it's just one right so i'm going to
write that as
1. and i also have i've solved what
function of
x t must be t of x is equal to
x so i'm going to swap these t's for x's
cos x plus i sine x
so this here and we don't need that one
i suppose because multiplying through by
that
doesn't change anything this here is the
result that we saw
before oh i'm going to grab that um set
of parentheses
with me anti so let's not do that this
guy here
is euler's formula you can see i
actually have proved that same result
that we went to
before but i've done it rigorously there
was no hand waving
and that's why it took so long and so
much careful thought with calculus
okay um so we should finish
right uh we have done a lot of work to
get here a few things that we
should note and uh let me just write a
heading so we can say what we're doing
here
so finish
firstly um we are now going to tie this
up in the complex
uh sorry the exponential form of a
complex number so you can see in order
to
get this in that form that we were
familiar with before um instead of
writing
x i would write thetas and instead of
saying oh
this this clearly has a modulus of one
it's on the unit circle right
um i want to have any complex number
which could be anywhere so you know
closer in or further away
so what i would say is my complex number
a
plus i b in rectangular form i could
equally write it as
r cos theta plus i sine theta
in polar or mod arc form or i could
write it as r
e to the i theta by uh simply
taking uh all my thetas in here sorry
all my x's and replacing them with
features
and then i just have to multiply the
left hand side
and the right hand side by r so you can
see how that gets us to
this result over here so what do we got
we've got
rectangular we've got polar
and we've got let's move that over
polar over here and then we've got
exponential
so um i want to make a couple of final
notes firstly
um even though a bit weirdly right this
guy here is clearly comes from
exponential form
you will sometimes if you go looking on
the internet sometimes or even some
textbooks will say this they will write
this
r e to the i theta and they will call
that polar form you might say
huh that's not polar form this is polar
form but i want you to think about
what does polar form mean um if you go
way back to the beginning what the idea
was was
you could define where a complex number
is first with horizontal and vertical
coordinates
or with a distance from the origin and a
direction that you're facing in
um that's the real thing right direction
and sorry
distance and direction you can see in
the way we've written exponential form
you've got the same pieces there
a distance and a direction so sometimes
this is also called polar form which
like i said is slightly confusing
i think a much better name for it is
exponential and nine times out of ten
when people say polar
this is what they mean here okay so
that's the first note
and then the second note is one of the
things that we've kind of from the
beginning of doing
working in polar form some of you might
have noticed i keep on writing things in
radians right i keep on saying pi on two
or pi and three pi and six five pound
six all that kind of thing
um and you will have noticed as an
example when we talk about the principal
argument um because we you know you can
keep on rotating round and round the
complex plane and you'll get the same
set of points
we define the principal argument
the principal argument we define it in
radians you will never see it written
in degrees it's going to be negative pi
less than x less than or equal to pi
and also note that weird sort of
asymmetry there right we include pi
we don't include negative pi because
those two arguments will give you the
same
spots now you can see it's all in
radians why why do we do this right
especially because a lot of you feel i'm
so much more comfortable in degrees
you'll even be mentally
doing um everything in degrees and then
converting over into radians okay
firstly try as much as you can i know
it's a new fresh idea relatively
speaking for you to work in radians but
it will be worth it to
start thinking more naturally in radians
to start not having to have that
translation step in your head it's very
error-prone
and takes you longer but the second
thing is you can see this entire
argument this entire
formal proof the guts of it like the
real machinery that made it all work
was pretty much like i don't know 95
calculus wasn't it um all this hard work
in here with all these derivatives we
had to differentiate
um with chain rule with product rule and
here's the most important part
we had to differentiate sine and cosine
now when you go back
and uh learn these these derivatives and
have a look at like
you know not just assuming we can like
draw a nice picture and it works
like using the first principles and
going back okay the actual results
upon which like the foundational results
for these guys themselves
are all based in radians these
derivatives actually don't work
in degrees they have to be in terms of
radians which is one of the chief
reasons that we learned it you might say
why do we have to change over and one of
the big reasons is so we can do calculus
with these trigonometric functions so
uh well done if you got to the end of
this and we're able to wrap your head
around it if you need to take a break
that would be totally fine i know there
is a lot in this but
one of the things that i think is great
is that even if you're not there
currently by the time you get to the end
of the course every part of this entire
proof whether it's the trigonometric
um derivatives or whether it was chain
rule or where whether it was integration
or this understanding of how to think
about different parameters like
t's and m's and and x's and r's and all
that kind of thing all of this
will form part of the fabric of how you
understand mathematics and complex
numbers so
i hope you find that find that helpful
and that you can take this as a result
that you can use
for lots of cool things as we're going
to explore further